a former high school cheerleader at the
center of a supreme court ruling on free
speech
says she's thrilled to have won the case
brandi
levy who has suspended for her team for
posting a string of curses
on her snapchat account in an eight to
one decision yesterday the court said
her school violated levy's first
amendment rights
jan crawford has been covering this
story jan what does this decision mean
for students free speech rights well you
know anthony i mean the question of
whether
schools can punish students for speech
that takes place off campus i mean
that's gotten a lot of attention in this
age of
social media and the court found here
that the school just went too
far but it said some off-campus speech
can still
be regulated when high school student
randy levy found out she didn't make the
varsity cheer squad
the teenager thought nothing of sharing
her disappointment with some profanity
on social media kids should be able to
express themselves
and they should be able to do so without
being scared that the schools are gonna
punish them
but her snapchat rant made its way to
the cheer coach who suspended brandy
from the junior varsity squad
randy and her father larry sued it
happened on a saturday
that's my due process as a parent to
resolve
a disciplinary incident that occurs on
my time that has no bearings to the
school district
the supreme court agreed ruling eight to
one that randy's
social media rant was protected by the
first amendment
when it comes to political or religious
speech that occurs
outside school or a school program or
activity the school will have a heavy
burden to justify intervention
rogesta steven ryer adding that
america's public schools are the
nurseries of democracy
i don't think it like fully sunk in yet
i mean like it
i i was really i was like screaming and
i was cheering
i'm not even gonna lie in my living room
when i found out the court said there
are times when schools can punish
students for what they say online
like for cyber bullying harassment or
threats
but not simply because a student's
expression seems inappropriate or
unpopular
it's like not only in favor of me but it
also is for millions of other kids
because it'll also
show other kids that it's okay to
express themselves
now this was a ringing defense of the
first amendment the most significant
case dealing with student speech to be
heard by the supreme
court in more than 50 years we are still
expecting more decisions from the court
this term including
what could be a pretty important voting
rights case
tony yeah kids should still be very
careful about what they say online but
the supreme court
very clearly sending a message that the
school anyway
shouldn't be policing it not in this
case thank you very much jan